German industry is grappling with its
future business and political
relationship with China CEOs of eight
firms including Siemens BASF and Bosch
write an open letter saying not to
decouple the company say it's right for
Germany to redefine this relationship
with China due to its increasingly
assertive behavior and human rights
issues but assist Germany needs to be in
China to stay competitive Chinese
investments in Germany have been in
Focus lightly as officials seek to
balance strong business relationships
with the need to avoid repeating
mistakes made with Russia
for more that's bringing Holger gerk
he's the president of the Keel Institute
for the world economy welcome to the
program so corporate leaders are warning
of a decoupling from China so that the
chancellor by the way prior to his
recent trip to Beijing do you see
decoupling tendencies
well I I see Tendencies and I think the
most important issue at the moment is to
keep calm um and
keep a clear head so I think it's clear
that China is one of the most important
trade partners for Germany but so is
Germany for China so their Mutual
relationships
um and these are both so China is very
important both as an export market for
German firms be it in the chemical
industry in engineering but also the car
industry but they're also of course an
important import source for many
products sold in Germany be it toys
consumer electronics but also very
important there's some raw materials so
there are these but of course
yeah please go ahead
no I was just going to say of course
there are the political tensions there
are the political problems to put in
mildly uh with the Chinese government
and that's not without problems and here
we of course talk about this state
influence in some state-owned
Enterprises that are problematic uh as
our political tensions that you already
mentioned earlier how much danger do
these strong ties that exist pose though
when Beijing is more than just
insinuating an attack on Taiwan which
would prompt International sanctions
well I I think the important Point here
is again to to keep in mind that these
relationships are both ways so
Germany is dependent on China in some
aspects uh but also so is China
dependent on Germany and that makes it a
very very different case to the case
that's uh very much present in the
German mind uh namely the case of Russia
and there the dependencies were very
very different
um so it is an issue of course it is an
issue that needs to be tackled by firms
and by the government
um
and it's a balancing act that we we have
at the moment and as I said it's
important there to keep calm and not to
panic and go off into a way that we we
can't come back from okay speaking of
staying calm how do you evaluate the
contingency plans of German companies in
case such a scenario meaning a Chinese
attack on Taiwan should become reality
um yeah I think
um I think these are company decisions
to be made or let's say there is uh
there is an important aspect here to
keep in mind I think in most cases
companies will make their own decisions
will make their own risk analysis and
will come up with contingency plans that
help them I think in a number of sectors
and they have to be thought about very
very critically what our critical
sectors what are sectors where we are
where we want to avoid a dependency here
companies have to work together with
government to to come up with a plan and
I think there's uh there's room for
improvement on that side China is
Germany's most important uh trading
partner what should a redefined
relationship look like
well I think it's important first of all
that companies themselves do their risk
analysis and I think uh as the CEOs have
said that's what they're already doing
secondly it's important that
Germany has a strategy about particular
sectors that it deems very very critical
and here the government will have to
work together with companies to come up
with
a plan on how to deal with this and and
thirdly I think it's very very important
to keep channels open for communication
I think dialogue is the key as it is to
with many problems in the world
Olga gerk president of the Keel
Institute for the world economy thank
you for your insights
thank you very much